Jordan if you look at the security there
are many parts of it yes one part is
government interference regulations laws
but then another part goes deep into who
we are I think the issue is not with how
security restricts creativity but how
actually have a room for creativity
while you maintain
[Music]
security
hello everyone watching and listening
today I am speaking with the Secretary
General of great Arab Minds his
Excellency SED El
nathari we discussed the origins of the
United Arab Emirates how the Abraham
Peace Accords and the tri Faith
initiative have taken effect and open
dialogue between the peoples of the
abrahamic faiths we discussed the
project spearheaded by SED for the
education entrepreneurial development
and empowerment of young
emiratis and how the unique vision and
strong values of the United Arab
Emirates have lifted the country to
Heights unimaginable only half a century
ago I've interviewed a fair number of
people from the Arab world and and from
the Muslim World more broadly and I've
also delved to some degree into the um
Abraham Accords which I'm very excited
about and I'm very much interested in
talking to you today about the United
Arab Emirates and so I thought we might
as well start with some really basic
questions because lots of people who are
listening won't know as much about your
country as they might and so the first
obvious thing to talk about is tell me
tell us exactly where you're situated
geographically who your immediate
neighbors are and and the size of the
country just the basic
details well Jordan thank you to have me
on
uh it's great to see you screen to
screen and hopefully very soon we'll be
meeting face to face in the
UAE uh the United Arab Emirates located
in the Middle
East
uh I'm not sure how accurate is
Wikipedia but it says you were born in
1962 Jordan if you look at the United
Arab Emirates in 1962 you would see an
area of
sand uh it had almost every single
reason for it not to be successful for
it not to exist it had every single
factor for it to be an impossible
Nation located in the Middle East one of
the world's most unstable region ongoing
conflicts in the Middle East tensions
failed
States and then beside that you have the
environment the harsh climate
heat
waves I just recently saw an article
that there are some Western cities May
face an environment or weather that's
somehow close to what the Middle East is
experiencing but in
20000 that risk comes 70
years to experience what we have been
experiencing for 50 years and then you
also had the infrastructure B basic
infrastructure uh I grew up listening to
stories about how hard it was to move
from one place to another uh how small
were the houses families were and very
limited small houses where you barely
have a place for your
bed uh you had all these factors the
unstable region the environment the
infrastructure yet here I am living in
one of the the most secured safe
cleanest diverse cities on Earth and
that's the UE the U we live in today
along with 200 different nationalities
it has one of the world's top
competitive cities Dubai Babi and many
other cities uh it have been a bacon of
Hope if it have been a
model that is homegrown in the Middle
East and it Prov
one thing that you have been discussing
for so long
Vision what does it mean to actually
visualize a vision visualize a goal I
think the UA is the ultimate case study
to showcase the power and impact of a
vision and so so tell me let's go over
some Basics again and then we'll talk to
the talk about the vision what's the
population of the UAE now it's almost
9.5 million and Dubai itself how many
people live there well the exact numbers
I don't have the exact numbers handy now
but there are millions as well and who
are your immediate neighbors who are you
surrounded
by we're surrounded by Gulf States you
have Saudi Arabia
Aman and many other countries there in
the Gulf States all right now you talked
about the vision of the UAE and and I
presume since we started talking about
1962 that there was very little in the
UAE in
1962 and you talked about the importance
of a vision so what was that vision and
how did the UAE develop both
economically and
socially Jordan if you look at the
history of the United Arab Emirates how
it was formed uh from basic uh
infrastructure uh some bwin families
living in many different areas small
houses uh small towns uh divided uh
areas uh our Founding Father the Le shik
Zed have came with a vision thought the
power comes in
unity uh the power and
Futures also could be made by unity he
thought we should unite different emirs
different tribes under One Vision that
Vision was to create hope out of the
stre region that Vision was to actually
build a nation that
represent us in a way that should be
represented globally who are we as
people of this region what are our
values what are our culture tradition
how can we turn every single challenge
into a solution uh into an opportunity
well if you look at the location being
in the Middle East is not something easy
it's f f with challenges it fills with
instability but then you could also turn
that into a huge opportunity you are a
hub to the whole world you are a a hub
to two billion people you could reach
East and West uh that's how you turn a
challenge into an opportunity if you
hear the uh the messages that have been
recorded by the uh
founder shik Z he was a very wise leader
who believed that he would
see uh this future coming he could
visualize stuff I can still hear some of
his TV interviews in 1971 and 1975 as if
he speaks about today's reality he
thought yes we will uh grow yes we will
focus on education yes we will focus on
trade on economy but then we will also
stick to our identity to our culture to
our values we will will send the message
of Hope out of this region because I
think our neighbors the 108 million
young Arabs are would love to see a
message of Hope out of this region we
have seen for so long many challenges uh
many conflicts happening uh and I think
there is a huge hunger and need to see
more messages of Hope coming out of this
region from this region for this region
to show a model that works what what
were the
Emirates and you you made reference to
tribal groups that were United what were
the Emirates exactly and when did they
unite when when did the when was the
country established the country was
established in second December
1971 at that day so it's very very new
country yes it's a young country and I
think I think being young made us all
see how vision and hard work could
actually turn the impossible into
possible who thought that in 50 years
time you could turn a place in the
middle of the desert into the wars trade
Hub into a place where it's among the
top 10 most competitive cities in Safety
and Security and trade and business uh
and you name it I think if I'll speak
about the rankings and I'll speak about
the competitiveness of the cities in the
United Arab emirat I can speak for the
next hour about how many uh stuff that
have been done in a way or in a quality
that could compete with any City around
the whole world and what were the
Emirates if you look at it uh well I
wasn't born in 1971 but what I hear from
my uh family my father my
grandfather it
was Desert Sandy area where you had 10
in some areas you had uh people who
would work in uh in farming in some
areas people who would go into fishing
and pearl diving and to trading uh I
think what was there back then it was a
trade Hub it have always been a trade
Hub because you trade with India you
trade with many other countries around
and but then the skills were different
the products were completely different
the Services were completely different
uh one thing was in Commons people
wanted to actually invest in themselves
and their families so they would even
fly to get educated they would also uh
go and meet uh in many different
universities or schools to actually get
access to education education was very
limited in the whole region uh most of
the services were were very limited but
I think our Founding Fathers
uh the leadership saw a potential saw an
opportunity saw a belief and this goes
back to the history of this region if
you look at the Golden Age of the
Arab uh this region were behind many
contributions we're behind many
Sciences you name it Al Jabra alism and
Medicine uh names of the exploration of
different Stars uh there were many
people in this region who contributed to
the fundamentals of these Sciences I
think this has been building our
confidence that we can do
it and that the way
today so you you said that say back
before
1971 the economy was rather rudimentary
and the governmental structure was
essentially tribal and shik zad United
all the all those various tribes now
they had been fractious for a long time
what did he do that brought the unity
about you made reference to Identity
culture and value but but I'd like to
know in more detail why did these tribal
groups decide to band together and why
has that maintained itself given as you
also pointed out the tremendous
instability that has characterized the
Middle East for well forever as as far
as of us living today are concerned so
what did how did he manage this vision
and what are the elements of identity
culture and value you think that unite
you and allow you to be prosperous I
think Jordan one thing that was clear
enough for everyone that the direct
intention that the late Z had he he
wanted good for everyone he wanted to
ensure that Unity bring better good for
everyone uh it didn't happen in one day
or one month he have been into that
continuous conversation with the ruler
of Dubai rash B with a ruler of
different areas at the United Arab
Emirates discussing how we can bring
Unity how can we build something that's
bigger than all of us uh that's what we
study in history that's what our parents
actually have experience and lived so my
uh my dad was following that these
discussion and everyone celebrated on
the 2 December 1971 when it happened
actually happened because they heard
about many Trials of unity in the region
many of them filed and many of them
didn't work but what made it work I
think that deep uh bold hard work uh
plan to stick to a vision and showcase a
vision uh with good
intentions with uh purpose and with
passion if you hear the speaks about
Unity or human resources he usually do
it with passion you can know how uh
honest he is you can know how how he
actually visualized that
vision and that's look at the way today
went from a Sandy place to exploring
Mars to uh right now we have an
astronaut at the International Space
Station so one of the things that
everybody who's watching and listening
might do well to consider is that um say
just made reference to the honesty of
shik shik zad
and we have this idea often in our
culture especially among the people who
are more cynical and N nihilistic that
if you're manipulative and you take
advantage and you win in your business
dealings and you're you're a hard ass
sort of Wolf of Wall Street kind of
character then you'll come up on top
with your dominance and your and your
willingness and ability to use force and
almost all that's nonsense I mean most
of the criminally Psychopathic oriented
types who use dominance they end up well
they often meet a violent end but
they're very rarely successful and the
reason for that is that you can fool
people once or twice but you can't fool
them consistently and this is actually
why I so interest interested why and how
the unity of the UAE was brought about
because in order to make something work
over well let's say Generations but even
over the span of a lifetime you better
not be lying to the people that you're
negotiating with because if you do they
will especially if you've come you know
like a wolf in sheep's clothing they
will not be happy about that and they
will absolutely take their revenge and
so if you want to be successful you said
he he did genuinely want the best for
the people of the region so he was
aiming up and he was honest and you can
get an awful long way aiming up and
being honest and so all right so he had
a vision and he was a trustworthy person
and he spoke with passion now how did
the UAE develop economically that was
primarily oil I I I presume and and and
but and people might think well the
reason the UAE is doing so well is
because it has oil and that's basically
cheap riches and it doesn't take a lot
of work to do well when you're receiving
billions of dollars but I would counter
that by saying that there are plenty of
countries on the planet that have no
shortage of Natural Resources um that
are corrupt beyond belief and that are
miserable Beyond
imagination and all of whose wealth is
devoted to a very small number of people
who are in fact very crooked and
everything is hell and so money alone is
not going to bring the kind of stability
and vision that you're talking about in
relationship to the UAE so what what te
tell us how the tell tell us how the
economy of the area has grown and how
you guys have determined to diversify
and to like stabilize your economy
across time well you say that Jordan oil
is an
enabler and you can't be over depending
on oil actually if you look at uh many
different countries oil could be a curse
sometimes uh because over dependence of
on oil would let you make short-term
decisions to actually increase your
revenue and so on what have been made in
the U is completely different actually
we started thinking of
diversifica diversification of the
economy right right away let's say Dubai
for example today 95% of the GDP is not
coming from the oil it's less than 5% %
depends on oil that's Dubai one of the
most competitive economies in the whole
region I think what we did very well is
turning of your problem into an
opportunity uh look we use location very
well to be a hub and a trade but then to
actually be a hub you need a
complete redesign of the environment you
need to design Logistics you need to
design enablers you need to design an
environment where people feel safe to
chase their dreams feel safe to actually
be part of what's being built and I
think that what made uh today's economy
the economy we see because everyone felt
that they want to be part of this thing
happening in the UAE part of bringing
hope to Life part of bring bringing
Vision to a reality part of challenging
uh every single obstacle I think it
became uh a sort of a movement that
Humanity felt we could see a
civilization being uh built here right
in the middle east in the UAE and then
you see many companies have trusted uh
the UAE and its stability they moved
their headquarters to the uh there are
many homegrown uh companies like herat
aine which is among the worst top
airlines Airline another great company
and then you have DP Ward handling many
ports worldwide uh you have many other
companies one after another and then you
have uh foreign investors coming uh I
think we we also went into advancing our
skills in many different Industries we
have now many Marais actually uh in many
different Industries and Logistics and
transportation and materials and
Engineering uh you they have different
companies they have products uh and we
maintain to have credibility on the way
we work we maintain to have uh also
consistency because if you look at the
UA in 1971 and then 1975 and then 1990s
2020 every year makes the UAE stronger
uh brighter
it it turns the story into a story of
vision that came true and a vision that
guides us for the next 50 years yeah
well you know my my daughter has spent
time in Dubai and she she's enjoyed a
lot she she said that the
entrepreneurial Buzz there is remarkable
um I suppose in algus in some ways to
Silicon Valley or maybe an algus at at
the moment to also modern Israel real
Hub of development she also said that
it's an extraordinarily safe and clean
and well-run City and I I have some
questions about that um so we had we I I
had talked to her about uh potentially
considering moving some of the
operations that I'm involved in to Dubai
and let me ask you the questions that
had come came to mind as a consequence
of that and you you must obviously know
the answers because you've attracted all
sorts of companies I know the tax
situation in Dubai is favorable to
people who are engaged in
entrepreneurial Enterprises the concern
one of the concerns I had was um let's
say the sanctity of private property I
mean a lot of people who've invested in
China have had second thoughts in recent
years because they've found that it
isn't obvious what exactly what they own
you know and one of the advantages to
being located in somewhere like the
United States in particular of the
United States but you could say the same
thing about Great Britain and most of
the countries derived from English
common law tradition is that if you own
something you can be pretty damn sure
that it's yours and that's a really hard
thing to establish right because in the
entire history of humankind one of the
most likely consequences of owning
something was that someone was going to
take it from you and now you said you
know the UAA has had a pretty good track
record for n on 50 years and that's
starting to become a reasonable amount
of time why do you think it is that
companies have trusted you to move their
assets to the UAA and why do you think
it is that they can trust you Jordan
well I'm I'm glad that your daughter
experienced what Dubai is and I'm very
excited for you to experience what Dubai
in the UAE is I think they don't they
didn't just move their Camp their
companies and businesses I think they
move their most valuable asset their
families uh I I hear hundreds and
thousands of stories of people who have
been moving to Dubai and bhabi and the
UA uh with their families uh growing
their children here in this environment
I think what we did very well and I
can't speak about the whole government
or the UAE but with my own personal view
is we designed an environment where we
feel
we we own what we work hard for uh now
currently the real estate market is
booming in Dubai U there are thousands
of people moving into Dubai there are
thousands of people buying in Dubai they
do that because basically they trusted
the system they trusted the government
they trusted the environment and you
can't buy trust there is no way you can
buy trust but you can build it and you
can earn it and this earning and build
comes in a result of a long credible
consistent hard work and a system that
works uh I live in this neighborhood in
Dubai uh in a very in every single
neighborhood you would find a marati
family you would find families from
Canada from uh UK from uh China from
Bangladesh you name it from India many
other uh people 200 different
nationalities have chosen Dubai to be a
place for their business for their
families for their growth uh they chose
the UAE because they know that living in
one
neighborhood walking at 3:00 a.m. at
night they wouldn't even face a
0.1% of a threat to their safety to
their security to their assets to their
privacy we have respect but we also have
order uh and order that works uh to
maintain a lifestyle that Humanity
deserve I think what we managed very
well is now they speak a a lot about uh
micro ecosystems and micro environments
when you try to design a micro
environment a garden a shading system in
your house where you design your own
micro environment I think what the UA
have been doing it designed a whole
micro W in Dubai and in maab and the UAE
where you would see the whole world the
ideal part of the world being flourished
here and that's why people trust uh
because they trust the system they trust
the order they trust the way it was
designed as the holiday season unfolds
it's a time of Joy gratitude and
reflection in the midst of all these
festivities consider taking a moment to
reflect on the digital footprint that
accompanies you through the season think
about all the information on your phone
from anything you search your location
to the websites you shop at and more
companies can legally gather this
information and sell your data for
profit that's why you need to do what I
do and keep your data private with
expressvpn expressvpn is an app on your
phone and computer that encrypts all of
your online traffic so whatever you do
stays private if you think incognito
mode will stop people from tracking your
online activity think again when you
read the fine print that appears when
you start browsing in incognito mode it
says that your activity might still be
visible to your employer your school or
your internet service provider without
expressvpn every site you visit could be
logged by the Admin of that Network we
love using expressvpn because of how
easy it is to use the app has one button
once you turn it on you're protected
from prying eyes the dailywire has
partnered with expressvpn to get you a
special holiday offer go to
expressvpn.com
Jordan right now and get three extra
months free go to expressvpn.com Jordan
right now and get three extra months
free that's
expressvpn.com Jordan expressvpn.com
Jordan to learn
more okay so so let me ask you some
questions about that you know I spent a
fair amount of time 25 years ago looking
at the difference between Japan and the
United States on the education front
also the economic front and uh this was
at a time I guess it was in the 1980s so
I guess that's more like 40 years ago um
when there was concern throughout the
Western World or apprehension that Japan
was going to be a monolithic and
dominating economic Force because it had
you know exploded onto the scene in in
an absolutely remarkable manner produced
a huge economy and one of the things
that struck me about Japan and uh was
that
it was in some ways a very very
conservative Society now there are some
advantages to that the Japanese
education system before University is
top rate their universities aren't very
good though and and that's relevant to
the to the place that I'm
going now in the
US the grade school system isn't as good
as the Japanese school but the
universities are a lot better and in the
US there's more crime but there's also
more creativity and if you look at the
curves for criminality and the curves
for creativity across the age span they
actually match pretty closely and that's
because there's actually a fair bit of
entrepreneurial Drive in criminal
activity so for example among drug
dealers in the United States drug
dealers are more likely than their peers
to also be
employed and so now I'm not making a
case for the benefit of of criminal
entrepreneurial ity my my point is this
is that it's very difficult to get the
balance between security and freedom
right right and if if you tilt towards
too much towards security you
risk suppressing people to the point
where you'll interfere with with
creative free enterprise expression not
just on the business side but on the
generally creative side and
so do I know that from all reports that
do is an incredibly safe environment and
you know you hear about you hear exactly
the same thing for for example with
regards to Singapore and Singapore also
is doing extremely well economically
but but the question arises in my mind
is that well are you buying that
security at the price of um a necessary
freedom and is it what's the evidence
that that's a re reasonable medium to
long-term trade so have add her i' I'd
like to know your thoughts on
that well Jordan if you look at the
security there are many parts of it yes
one part is government interference
regulations laws and stuff that we we
maintain to maintain security and order
but then another part goes deep into who
we are our DNA which character we build
in our people uh and that goes into the
society into the environment into
Generations I think what we managed to
do is we we managed to build people or
attractive and people who can know the
difference between Order and Chaos who
can know the difference
between having a secured environment
safe environment and having a creative
environment which is which also could be
uh Al long with that
environment I think the issue is not
with how security restricts creativity
but how actually have a room for
creativity while you maintain security
and there are many uh opportunities
where you can see that happening in
Dubai if you just Google Dubai or Google
do a search on the most beautiful
buildings worldwide or when did Humanity
uh actually showcase their creativity in
the way they build the stuff and the way
they design stuff you would always hear
Dubai you would always see Dubai uh we
have creative artists designers from all
over the world came to this place to
actually showcase their creativity to
actually uh also showcase where humans
can show different ideas we have ideas
on tolerance ideas on connectivity ideas
on culture differences and similarities
uh we hosted the word Expo
uh export
2020 uh where almost every single
country participated designed something
that represent that nation and showed
the whole world on what are their values
and beliefs and their culture and it was
like a beautiful competition where we
compete on building better civilization
better future for uh for Our Generations
uh and that's happening right away it
was live in Expo 2020 and Dubai uh and
yet zero crimes at Expo 2020 extremely
safe environment uh I guess the number
reached 25 million visitors uh to that
show uh the Expo 2020 show and you see
that happening every day you have zones
you have the Clusters like the Dubai
internet City Dubai Design District
Dubai Media city where you have people
from all over the world coming in uh to
work and build and design something so I
think if you design the right
environment and then build the right or
embed the right values in people's
DNA you can actually hit the formula
right okay okay so let's let's talk
about that for for for a minute I mean
one of the major contribut contributors
to criminality and general chaos in the
west and that's particularly true at the
moment in the United States is the rise
of single parent families right
fatherlessness kids especially
fatherless boys because they're much
more likely to grow up to engage in UNT
behavior and so that raises a question
which is if you're not going to rely on
oppression and the police for example to
maintain security but you want to build
uh a society that's predicated on values
that are solid so that security and
creativity can can both flourish what
are the values that you have to
instantiate and so what do you think
that you're doing right on the value
side with regards to your culture that's
providing
this more optimized mix of security and
creativity I think uh Jordan part of
that comes from who we are uh if you
look at the Arabic values Arabic culture
the values of this region uh for decades
have been based on tolerance based on
accept ing others based on generosity
based on the golden rule that many
different faith and religion speaks
about that you wish for others what you
wish for yourself hundreds of and of
quotes and examples and stories about
that that what our parents and families
speaks about the the our
responsibilities towards the community
towards neighbors you will find it in
our faith you would find it in Islam you
would find it in our culture hospitality
is a huge thing in the Arabic culture
you would see it in the Traditions you
would see it in every single part of our
culture and looking at all of these I
think we managed to build a character
and character building is something that
uh somehow turned to show its results
today because when you build a character
with the right set of values you embed
the right set of values you actually
also build immunity immunity against uh
different thoughts that may not work
align with who we are and that's
something very very important for us to
maintain as a legacy that yes we are a
global City yes we are part of a the
whole world but then we also know
exactly how to differentiate between
what represents our value and what
doesn't represent our value this doesn't
mean that we will disrespect the other
this doesn't mean that we may
always uh put a block in different
thoughts we learn we grow but then when
you build that immunity system I think
it works like how our body works it
knows which vitamins or which part to
take and which part to leave or actually
defend against and that's what we made
uh I think it it's it happened I see it
I see it every every day I see it in
families I see it in parents I see it in
school I see it in universities where
even before you see an action in
government I think you would see people
to mentioning that oh this idea actually
represent who I am and this doesn't
represent who I am I think we should
maintain this for the Next Generation
because you see how the words getting uh
scary to see where the word heading in
some areas uh you you scroll down on
your phone you may see uh Jordan
Peterson speaks about vision and
personality but then you you swipe and
see some horrible ideas on uh different
Acts or different beliefs that I don't
that aims to takes us back 100 years ago
or 200 years ago or takes us into chaos
and here is I think where we build the
immunity and the wisdom wisdom of of
picking the right decision so so I I I'm
particularly curious on the family front
how
what to what degree are families in in
the UAE still traditionally intact
rather than
broken what's your divorce rate like I
don't know if you have those stats at
hand and maybe you don't um and what's
the birth rate because you know in the
west the birth rate in many countries is
plummeted far below replacement it's and
it's part it's part of the fractionation
of the family and that seems like a very
very bad long-term strategy so how are
you guys doing on the birth rate and
divorce front and what's the typical
structure of a family in in the
UAE well I usually prefer to be accurate
when it comes to numbers but then I
don't have the numbers handy yet uh if
you look at how the lifestyle of
families here in the United Arab
Emirates I could
see my family
itself the bonding is all the family is
always a big thing here the family
always comes first the family always is
the the first guiding uh campus for us
on where are we heading uh who we are uh
what are our beliefs and values uh and I
think we have many rituals where we
actually always allocate some time
to spend days spend uh different uh
occasions with family like just last
week was the Eid holiday where you'd see
families Gathering it's a celebration
for everyone and then I know most of the
families around where they we they meet
every week and uh we used to have way
bigger families before uh where almost
every family consists of five to six
members maybe with the
uh the current busy lifestyle numbers
sometimes get decreased a bit but I
think the value of family stayed very
very strong well I've got some stats
here that are very interesting so in
2018 in the UAE the divorce rate stood
at
12% and then it was 133% in
20192 but it dropped in 2021 to 9 and
continued its downward Trend in 20 22 to
3% testifying to the development of
processes and interactive programs that
have proven beneficial to the parties to
the conflict so it looks that's Abu
Dhabi judicial outreach program succeeds
in reducing divorce rate to 3% so it
looks like you're doing pretty good on
the divorce rate front um the the birth
rate let me just check that because
that's also an that's also an issue of
Interest let's see what have we got here
on the bir rate 1.46 per wom per woman
so it's it's it's it's low but not as
low as it is in many countries so now
okay so now you talked about the values
that stabilize the country that make it
secure and that also allow for
creativity and maybe we've gone over
this but I'm going to hit it one more
time those values in the Middle East
have been around for a long time
including the value of hospitality but
the region still has been extremely
fractious now you've quelled that to a
large degree in the UAE and so I'm still
curious about that you've you've
obviously done something like
universalize these values so that they
can Embrace a larger number of people
but and you said you did that through
passionate leadership and vision and
trust and and then fortunate economic
circumstances and maybe maybe that's
maybe that's a sufficient answer maybe
we'll maybe we'll turn to something else
yes I a couple of other things um what's
the situation with women's rights in the
UAE and and how is that similar or
different to the to the to the to the
state that obtains in the countries
around
you well the case for Women rights and
gender balance in the UAE is very very
unique I think it's competitive
worldwide if you look at the workforce
in our government for example more than
60% are women uh uh I have worked in 12
different jobs six of them I had female
managers uh in many cases uh woman
rights is something we have been
raising uh and growing and having it as
a priority priority uh we it's part of
who we are again uh I have I have a
daughter who I think every single member
of this family have celebrated from the
day she were born when she is born she
she got a letter from the UA president
uh telling her that we want you to
actually represent the values of the l z
we want you to carry that Legacy forward
and then women get educated and I think
we are on the top highest rates from
moving to school to University worldwide
uh in terms of how
many graduate women we have I think the
rights women have in every aspect of uh
of the the quality of life here in the
United Arab Emirates you could see the
the balance you could see the
the the support you could see everyone
enable her to flourish enable her to be
who she uh to build a family to build a
career to build a success uh look at
marriage uh there are hundreds of
policies to actually support uh marriage
look at uh uh being in the workforce
there are lots of policies Now with
harrid uh model of work uh with uh
flexibility in hours and timings and
attendance and all these stuff I think
it made it even not only easier but Al
also made it even safe to be who you are
if you decided to focus on your family
or you focus on your studies or focus on
your office uh working hours or focus on
your career growth or your business you
can basically get support and the
government will handle its
responsibility and families will handle
its responsibility to celebrate you
wherever you are and uh so you may hear
that many people actually called let's
say
my name is but some people call me bu
which means the father of Shem and we
have that in Arabic tradition where they
know that the most valuable thing for a
man is his daughter or his son so they
name me after my daughter that's how
much we respect actually uh woman or how
much I respect my daughter and and
actually I feel proud every time I hear
her name and I want to be the best
father I could or be the best best
employee I could for her and for many
others finally some good news because of
you my friends over at preborn have
rescued over 44,000 babies this year
alone right now thousands of mothers are
awaiting the birth of their precious
babies and thousands upon thousands of
babies are taking their first breath
since its Beginnings pre-born network of
clinics has rescued over
280,000 babies that is a miracle see the
overturning of Wade only made them more
ravenous for the innocent so now we need
to be more passionate to save them
thanks to pre-born we can do just that
for just $28 you can Empower a mother to
choose life once she sees the precious
life growing inside of her and hears
that baby's heartbeat she is twice as
likely to choose life and right now
through a match your gift is doubled
please give your most generous gift that
will go 100% toward life have your
donation double today by dialing pound
250 and saying the keyword baby that's
pound 250 keyword baby or donate
securely at preborn
docomo that's preborn
docomo so now it seems to me although
Saudi Arabia has been liberalizing its
attitude towards um women's rights in
recent years it seems to me that there's
a marked difference between the UAE and
Saudi Arabia on the women's rights front
and so why did those two societies
develop in different directions and what
do you see happening in Saudi Arabia on
the women's rights
front well I like how I think the region
is
diversed if you spend time in Dubai and
then go and spend time in Cairo or spend
time in Muscat or spend time in Aman is
different yes there are common values
they are always I language there is
always Islamic Traditions but then the
way the societies live or grow is
completely different there's different
opinions there's there are different
point of views and I think the region is
somehow heading to a very bright
positive side uh I see something
happening in the region I see hope in
the region when I meet uh young Arabs
when I meet decision makers in the
report uh Dubai just hosted World Expo
and now you Saudi Arabia is applying to
host World Expo Doha hosted the World
Cup uh you have many other cities are
planning to build new cities build uh on
new islands have new tourism experiences
and I think that goes back to an event
that I attended in Riyad in Saudi Arabia
where the conference had a talk there
and he
said in back in 90s he saw a man or a
leader that showed and proved to the
whole region what could be possible and
how to design and build something Global
out of this region and that person was
his muhamad the UA prime minister uh it
made me feel proud at that moment of who
we are and what's our impact but then I
see it everywhere Jordan I don't see it
only on Jesus I even see it across the
globe uh I see articles I uh I saw an
article on BBC where it it was about the
next Dubai of Africa where could be the
next Dubai be in Africa where could be
where are the next growing cities in the
Middle East or many different areas I
like how the UAE how Dubai how Babi
became a
model that works and that shows you can
actually achieve what
what your dreams or Vision are in a very
short time and your age and my age we
can actually build a whole nation so so
let's talk about your I'd like to talk
about the the the international scene a
little bit now and so um your how are
your relationships with your immediate
neighbors and so I I want to know that
and what what what direct influence you
think the success of the UA has had on
their development strategies let's start
with that how are your relationships
with your immediate neighbors who who
are your strong allies who do you feel
that you're collaborating with to build
a more positive vision of the future on
the Arab side okay I'm I'm not a
diplomat uh I won't speak on behalf of
uh our embassies or our
ambassadors but what I see is UA have
maintained a positive relationship a
respecting relationship with almost
every single country worldwide that's
why we gained trust from many different
countries that why we became the word a
smaller word in this nation uh you would
see us participating in every single
Mission or act that helps Humanity grow
uh look at the numbers look at the
numbers you would see the way among
always among the top five when it comes
to foreign aid when it comes to support
human human Arian activities that goes
back to
1971 you would see many hospitals many
schools many universities many clinics
worldwide are named after the or named
after the
UAE just recently I was in Washington DC
and I met a friend of mine there he he
told me I actually go for my Clinic
appointments to a hospital where the UA
invested uh heavily ion for its research
for its services in Washington DC and
the same you would hear it in many
different countries where actually you
would see the UA and Leadership
footprint there that there is something
uh good happening there is that what
again built credibility in this country
that's again built why this country is
special this country is different uh you
would hear many head of States speaks
proudly about their partnership with the
UAE uh it's a small country but it show
the whole word that you could actually
have a a huge impact what's your
relationship let's talk a little bit
about the Abraham Accords and your
relationship with Israel what what's
happening on that front and um what are
the challenges and advantages to those
to such
initiatives you you have lived it you
have hear it for 20 30 years
conflicts and tensions we didn't see a
result uh I think there were no winner
in conflicts and tensions the UA took a
whole different
directions uh the UA took the direction
of actually looking at peace and
tolerance but then be brave and bold
enough to act on peace and tolerance we
all want we all in campaigns uh in
strategy say that we want to be more
tolerant more accepting more respecting
but then what
proves all these campaigns or all these
beautiful messages is what are your
actions or what are your movements
toward peace and I think that something
we have showed very clearly in the UAE
where you would see everyone from any
other nationality any religion that
would feel respected it will feel safe
and actually feel feel inspired feel
inspired to accept the other and feel
inspired to see what brings us together
I can spend this our uh Jordan to speak
about how close we are when it comes to
thoughts or I can also look at that it
from a very dark lens where we see how
different we are uh I think we chose the
right lens we chose to be also a Beacon
of Hope uh to send that message loud to
even Inspire others if it's works in the
U and you see peace actually in action
in the UAE you see uh respecting
different cultures and nations are
happening here right now why do you want
to wait for for for you to actually be
more tolerant uh I think no one will win
against
tolerance so you're you know you you
mentioned earlier that you see in Dubai
um a
competition
between different modes of productivity
and generosity let's say who could who
can make the best offer you know and I
I've been thinking this through on the
religious front we H in the world we
have three major
religions
um emerging from from the Middle East
all part of the abrahamic tradition all
monotheistic all people of the book um
embroiled in internally in conflict over
nominally religious matters ma matters
for centuries in the west and in in the
Middle East and then also engaged in
conflict between the major religions um
and it seems to me that you know we're
at a point in our historical development
where where what we should be engaging
in is something like a competition of
invitation and you could say well you
know if you have faith in your tradition
then you could be an avatar of that
tradition and you could live in the most
no manner you could possibly imagine and
if you turn out to be a shining beacon
on the hill and other people are
attracted well then you win and that's a
good competition and now I know there
have been multifaith initiatives in the
UAE um it has a tradition of I don't
think religious tolerance is exactly the
right word it's it's more like something
approximating a genuine appreciation for
diversity do you want to talk a little
bit about what's been happening in the
uee on the faith on the faith side on
the because I think that's that strikes
me as extremely
important and the UE you would find
mosques you would find churchs you would
find synagogues uh we have the abrahamic
house in
Babi I think what what we have
been building here in the UAE is
actually an environment where we respect
every single religion and we respect our
different differences in a way that we
accept others we accept what's different
and what and we focus on what brings us
together like I had a conversation with
many from different faiths and we were
speaking about leadership building and
about character building and then the
name Prophet Moses came a prophet who
who we do respect and uh the
counterparty spoke to me about a a
leadership program where they designed
based on the Journey of prophet Moses uh
and how he
actually became who he is and who he was
and that's something we really
appreciate in the Islamic culture and
Islamic tradition uh because that story
is in our Quran you would see it in
Bible you would see it in many other
books and I think focusing on areas
where we see how different faith faith
brings different uh messages or uh
different different stories or different
values uh and see where are the common
areas I think that's where our strength
come from and uh and there are hundreds
and thousands of areas where you could
agree and I could agree and many other
people from many different faiths could
agree that yes this is part of who we
are or this is part of who we believe in
or this is the God we worship uh and
that's how we worship him and that's how
we actually serve
our nation our planet our
community well one of the most
remarkable initiatives that I've seen in
recent years along with the Abraham
Accords which established peace between
Israel and a variety of Arab states is
the abrahamic family house which is a um
very impressive complex that has on the
same site a mosque a church and a
synagogue and you know that seems to me
to be
symbolically emblematic of what's
happening in the UAE now that Rec that
just opened recently I I believe right
that's opened what in the last is it is
it the last six months it's certainly
within the last year yes it is and so um
what what is the conse what has been the
consequence of that Enterprise and um
how was it set in motion why did it
succeed today I was spending some time
on social media and a VI a video of a
student I think almost seven years old
student came out that he actually went
to a tour with his family to that
abrahamic house and he was telling the
whole world I think sorry was among 10
12 years old I'm not sure how old he was
but he was telling the whole word that
oh look at this place where actually
Muslims Christians Jews could worship in
different buildings uh that represent
present their different worships or
different Faith worshiping one God uh
actually happened here right away in
Dubai in Abu Dhabi this place is
public it it built on an idea that's
simple yet bold and
sharp just think about
it many different religious religions
faiths people from many different Faith
coming together in one place living with
peace it's actually possible it's
happening you don't need a magic stick
for it to happen you you will need to
design the right environment for it to
happen the right conversations the the
right dialogue the right inspiration for
Next Generation and I I don't see any
challenge to bring it to life to bring
it to bring us all of us together and
closer yeah well that would wouldn't
that be a wonderful thing I mean you
know I I I was ill for a couple of years
and wasn't paying much attention to
initiatives on the international front
but when I sort of sprang back to life
in
2020 um one of the first things I turned
my attention to was the Abraham Accords
and the fact that something genuinely
new and positive seemed to be emerging
in the Middle East and like it was a big
deal and I was quite stunned by in some
ways by how little attention was paid to
that in the West because it struck me as
one of the most vital developments on
the international front well certainly
in the last 50 to 70 years but perhaps
even beyond that especially if it's
Allied as you're pointing out with an
actual transformation of vision you know
if if if we could tilt things the
collective we if we could tilt things so
that we started to regard people of
Faith let's say as allies instead of as
mortal enemies then God only knows what
we could produce and I would also say
that the people of the abrahamic faiths
let's say have bigger fish to fry on the
enem enmity front than each other you
know there's there's uh uh and this is
particularly relevant in the west if the
traditional religious structures
collapse all sorts of bizarre systems of
belief um make themselves manifest as a
replacement and as far as I can tell
those Replacements aren't all that
desirable
and so it's it seems to me to be only
wise on the parts of part of Jews
Christians and Muslims to look to what
they have in common and to Foster that
and it's very very heartening to see uh
country like the UAE which can punch
above its weight and which is small
enough to be governable but large enough
to be a model to actually take the
initiative on this front I'm I'm very
much looking forward I'm going to go to
the UAE I think I'm going in October in
early October I'm very much looking
forward to going to Abu Dhabi and seeing
this Tri Faith establishment that's for
sure and then also obviously to see the
other cities I'm very much looking
forward to that because I think it's a
huge deal this is this is something of
historical significance the
establishment of the abrahamic house you
know the fact that you were able to do
it that it's been successful I know that
it was in let me see
here uh the pope visited in
2019 um it was the first by a pope to
the Arab Arabian Peninsula during that
trip he signed a joint declaration with
the grand Imam of Alazar that called for
religious tolerance and dialogue it's
like well you know hey how a little more
of that would be a very very good thing
so that's all extraordinarily positive
and so all right so let's turn our
attention a little bit more specifically
to the sorts of projects that you've
been involved with you have spearheaded
50 projects a lot of them concentrating
on youth so why don't you delve into
what you've been doing on that front um
because I'm very curious we talked
before this part partly what brought
this podcast about I we had a
conversation previously about um what
might be done on the psychological front
to end the demoralization of young
people and to provide them with a
certain amount of Hope and um it's c the
case that helping young people develop a
vision for the future is a is well an
obvious necessity but also an
extraordinarily coste effective and
efficient way of guiding developing
Souls into a beneficial and productive
and generous future you've been doing
such things for a very long time so why
don't you walk us through some of your
projects so
Jordan I'm I'm also very excited for you
to visit and experience the UAE and one
part of UAE being a young country most
of our population are actually young
people almost 50% of uh the UA's
population are young under the age of
35 uh the U government have established
a minister of State for youth Affairs
and have established I think it took the
the boldest and the biggest steps when
it comes to Youth Empowerment uh you
would hear people speaking about Youth
Empowerment uh in many different
countries uh in panel discussion and
round tabls and in many occasions these
are strategies that Management
Consultant offered 500 major strategies
that end up in the desk or sometimes end
up to be a recommendation or discussion
and you don't see it all from a reality
or you don't see uh actual steps taken
by the government uh to transform all
these recomend recommendation into
actionable uh results or facts and
figures the case is completely different
in the united arabis I used to work uh
as a director general for for the
federal Youth Authority uh what my main
ultimate mandate was to
actually ensure we designed the right
environment for young people to reach
their full potential and today if you
look at the young people of the United
Arab Emirates you would see that spark
in their eyes they want to be part of
something bigger that's something that I
always wanted to be part of back in
2009 uh when I was a high school student
like many other young people I thought
what would I want to be part of why do
uh where where I'm heading what's the
work I have I want to uh accomplish or
what are my
achievements one ultimate source of
inspiration was the UA leadership I saw
the Prime Minister working on many
different projects working on delivering
uh different clusters different economic
achievements different uh stuff when it
comes to uh to infrastructure and so on
so like many other young people I went
and ask the big question on where I'm
heading where do I want to 10 years from
now that was back in 2009 so I found the
prime minister's who page and back then
hot mail was something cool and everyone
used to mail uh others and I found a
link to actually email the Prime
Minister and I ended up emailing the
Prime Minister telling him that I'm
amazed with all these achievements I'm
amazed with the way you transform vision
and reality and I want to to be part of
this I want to be part of your team I
want to be part of this purpose I want
to actually help others the way I saw
you
guys inspired me inspired me to be part
of something bigger and I send that
email in many countries you would think
there are 10,000 20,000 50,000 of emails
goes to the leadership and or sometimes
ending up in with the assistance I
didn't have big expect
I thought maybe maybe one day among the
100 or 1,000 emails that my email could
reach to the Prime
Minister surprisingly enough few days
later I get an email
says Dear s ambitious is great work hard
look at the role models around believe
in what we are building and one day
you'll have the opportunity because
every single young person here here in
this country would have an
opportunity it was signed personally by
the the Prime Minister
himself I I kept that email printed and
framed in my office I remember 10 years
from that email uh I met the Prime
Minister for one of the events he was in
my
office during that time the smile I saw
uh the the moment I lived I felt every
second and deep inside I felt That's The
Power of having the right role model
That's The Power of actually having and
visualizing a vision and then working
hard for that Vision to happen and
that's the moment where I thought I
should be part of and be responsible to
help others find their goal find their
path find their role models that's when
I ended up being part of uh the Youth
Empowerment initiatives and policies uh
we have many policies and projects where
it sets young people into their priority
they are the one who designed their
strategy they are the one who design
their policies uh we used to have uh
circles where we actually have the
top decision makers young people
students discussing certain problems or
certain challenges and then actually
Empower them to design the solution it's
stuff related to education to mental
health to housing and let me give you an
example on housing uh we had we had uh
the public policy adviser we had a
decision maker participating in one of
the circles and we were young people
discussing well building a house is not
a task that is as easy as we think
because many of us are not designers or
not engineers and and sometimes you will
need proper budgeting you would need
proper timeline processes and so on and
we discussed maybe part of the solution
could be actually to have a one1
fundamental course or guideline to help
young people take that step and there
were the government a week later signed
a policy by the Prime Minister where
actually it equips and train people to
take that Milestone forward to actually
be prepared to build their house and we
have the same for building a family we
have the same to actually joining a
Workforce or a university we have a lot
of enablers and we have policy okay the
same meaning okay yeah okay so so the
same meaning you you you talked about
family you talked about career um you
you talked about education these
enabling processes what what what
exactly do you do and and how how many
people is that affecting and how do you
know what the effect is so how do you
enable the young people on all these
fronts well we design products products
and policies and services so one example
we have a policy where in every single
government Authority or in department or
agency you allocate a seat for young
people where a young person would be
part of that board uh would be part of
that board meeting would be part of that
discussion to actually transfer young
people's views into the ultimate
decision Mak layer at that Authority
that's one that policy is signed you
have seats allocated for young people
you wouldn't find that in any government
worldwide where we allocate a seat for
young person every single board uh
another initiative or policy was
actually designing different uh youth
councils across the country across
institution across cities we have the
Dubai youth Council the ababi youth
Council uh we have councils across
companies like M youth Council uh DP WS
youth Council we have an agencies and
Ministries where you have the ministry
of economy youth Council this youth
councils acts as uh representation of
what Young what young people Aspire from
these different Ministries or these
different Corporation and they sit uh
high enough to have a direct engage
engagement uh with the leaders actually
have some they actually have some
influence exactly they they do have not
just proor yes they do have influence
they have the toolkit they have the
support they have the enablers uh and I
think what's very very special in the
United Arab Emirates is that direct
bonding between young people and the
leadership uh go in the streets in the
neighborhood during your visit a random
survey on how many young garais are
actually met the the president himself
you would find numbers and answer that
you couldn't find in any other country
worldwide
uh our president desik Muhammad bin Zed
I think he designed an engagement model
between leadership and young people that
doesn't exist anywhere uh he opens his
place every week sometimes every Monday
sometimes every Tuesday where anyone I
could go and visit and discuss some of
my aspirations or discuss some of the
challenges I'm facing uh he is part of
where are we hidden uh when I got
married I got a letter from him uh on
congratulations on your marriage and
then he he also I have met him almost
five times that's me I think there are
hundreds of others and thousand people
who met him maybe 10 times or 20 times
uh but that built the TR trust so if you
look at the formula on why the UA is
successful in terms of Youth in terms of
economy we have the vision we have a
leadership that we trust and we trust
because they represent who we are and
when it comes to values but they also
show performance performance that is
exceptional I think uh if you look at
the achievements and the deliverables
and the policies signed uh during during
uh crisis during hardest times it shows
that this leadership not only care about
this country but cares also about the
generation would would come 10 20 30
years from now and part of it comes from
the
responsibility of representing the
founding father's value uh uh I remember
one of the occasions where the UA
president had to meet one of the state
leaders in one of the buildings
and I was there at that building and I
saw his agenda I know he had a long
program then while he walked in in the
building he actually spent time to have
a direct interaction he came uh not only
to say hi but to also ask
about any challenges we face or ask
about our dreams have that conversation
I think what this leadership show in the
United Arab Emirates it gives people the
value the value they deserve uh I have
been living in the United Arab Emirates
I never ever saw any part of the ruling
family cross a signal the street uh I
saw them in our weddings I saw them in
our with us in our hardest time I saw
them actually leading projects and going
into the field to see their projects and
vision coming uh to life and I don't and
you would see that and you would
experience that during your visit
because it's facts and Figures it's
numbers it's achievements it's not an
emotional op opinion but is a credible
opinion do you feel like there's there I
would say there's widespread
demoralization among young people in the
west and I think that's particularly
true of young
men and I think the reasons are
basically
threefold the first is is that we do a
very bad job of managing the play
preference and the activity preference
of boys in our Early Education System
and so our elementary schools are not
welld designed for what boys need and
then on the ideological front we insist
at every possible turn that any
manifestation of masculine ambition is
part of the P system of patriarchal
oppression that's uh what would you call
wreak havoc in a demonic way since the
beginning of time and so the boys learn
to identify their ambition with with uh
pathological power and then if they
manage to escape those two things then
the next thing they're told is that all
human activity is nothing but
destructive that we're taking the planet
into an environmental apocalypse and
that everything's going to collapse in
any case and it's the fault of Human
Action and the combination of those
three things is uh you could add
pornography into the mix just to mop up
any boys that might have escaped from
those three things and we've done a
pretty spectacular job of demoralizing
young people in the west and it's not
pretty and so would you say that in the
UAE that the young people that are part
of your culture are looking to the
future with hope I mean I know you're
you're putting forward an optimistic
vision and and it's a credible vision
and it's credible because there are
markers of its success right it's not
just talk but you know at least to some
degree what's happening in the West on
the ideological front and the
demoralization front do you think that
you guys have been successful at
providing a positive vision and
motivating while young men in particular
we talked about young women already you
you've got the women's rights um
approach fully active you said women are
well integrated into your culture at
every level are are your young people
looking forward to the future with a
certain degree of hope so Jordan I have
studied with young people worked with
young people and also been Ser uh
offering public service to young people
part of my mandate was to actually
interact with young people on daily
basis and what I saw is not just hope I
actually saw a drive a drive to build
something big to build the next big
thing for this nation to actually turn
another impossible into possible and we
have many examples on uh stuff that
happens in schools and
universities
uh 10 years ago if you ask a young man
would you ever dream to go to the space
or would you all what would be your
dream I don't think the the answer about
going or exploring a space with
exist back then in their report uh it
was something almost impossible it was
something that's far away you don't see
young Arabs actually exploring space for
so for decades for 30 40 years now if
you go to the schools in the United Arab
Emirates and meet many young uh kids and
young men many of them would say we want
to be the next astronaut who goes and
explore uh space because they have
someone
and they have a role model that exists
today we took that box we made it
possible we turned something impossible
into possible we turned the whole dream
into an actual visual story and we have
many of these stories in the UI where
actually men could see others do it and
they feel that oh I can also do it I can
also design my own startup I can also be
part of this Mission I can also be part
of this uh program actually if you look
at the cabinet uh many members of the
cabinets are young ministers they are
under the age of 35 they are under the
age of 30 uh they are ministers of
economy Ministers of artificial
intelligence minister of Youth affairs
minister of Community Development and in
a way showcase again hope in many
different formats uh and that goes back
to the whole region there were a survey
called the arw
survey now they did it almost 10 times
every time they they questioned almost
3,000 young Arabs every time the UAE
became the ideal location for them to
actually follow their dreams and every
time they saw the UA model as a model of
Hope and a model of optimistic future
and not only when it comes to views or
how we see the future but actually how
we design it and how we build it uh you
go and walk in the United Arab Emirates
you would find incubators everywhere for
young entrepreneurs you would find youth
hubs where actually either if you were
an artist a musician uh a scholer a
writer a researcher where you can have a
whole path uh one thing that we did very
well
Jordan is basically we we taught people
how to find their point B and then how
to go and walk that way toward point B
because not knowing the destination is
scary and it it creates that Gap and
hopeless yes exactly if you look at most
of the challenges Arab youth face a big
part of it because many of them are
hopeless or many of them didn't find
hope in a way uh almost 70% of PhD
holders in the reward are living outside
Theo and there where we have uh an an
initiative called the greater of Minds
uh an initiative that was launched last
year the ultimate idea and purpose and
objective of this initiative is actually
to build role models in medicine in
physics and chemistry in economy in
Technology and Engineering and in design
it's an award that's not only
contributes with the financial rewards
but actually it recognized different
contribution it recognized uh the the
gems we have in the aort uh for so long
many of our scientists and Scholars uh
were hidden gems in our society and
sadly uh in our communities in in the
Arab word if you look at the numbers
many are leaving the boort and that's
something uh I don't mind people chasing
their future anywhere but then we should
also understand that the Arab world
needs them the most it needs more role
models for the 108 million young Arabs
in science and economy and design that's
where the UA came up with this
initiative uh which I'm currently busy
with is actually not to explore who are
our hidden gyms and turn them into
visible gyms uh but also to recognize
them to empower them to reward them
sometimes all what they need is a pat on
the back they want someone to tell them
well done you have done it you are a
role model for our kids uh and sometimes
we do that late you have you have many
names in that report like look at Z she
was a
designer she she built and designed
buildings in many different places in
the whole world I think today
we value her and we we notice her value
but then who is our current who is our
current ibun of psychology who is our
current and the in the wholeo and that's
what we are trying to find and I think
this is the ultimate message of Hope and
confidence because part of what we do is
we build confidence in people if the UA
made it
if someone made it to the space station
if someone built a city in 50 years the
most ideal and one of the world's best
cities you can also do it so let's let's
um let's turn for a moment
to tell me a little bit about what
problems you see besetting the UAE what
what what are the major challenges that
you guys are dealing with at the moment
and maybe we can conclude after that
with a description of where you'd like
to things had over the next 10 years but
let's start with challenges what are the
major challenges that you face in the
UAE I think we Face challenges that are
similar challenges that many nations and
generations are facing
worldwide one thing is the impact of
social media and the impact
of uh bringing everything closer uh well
that had a very
uh positive uh impact on doing business
on work on studying an education but
also showed some threats that we some I
see in many different areas worldwide
people are losing their identity they
are losing their hope or sometimes I
don't know how can I define what we see
in many different parts of the whole
world so my
ultimate goal always for that's I see it
for myself and my family how to ensure
that we we have that immunity and we
have that guarding values to ensure that
not only my generation can take the
right decision but my daughter's
generation could take again the right
decision and her next Generation could
be also take the right Generation Well
the well well the problem the problem
with that information influx as you said
it's very very rich but it it's also
sufficiently um overwhelming to be uh a
dissolvent and a and an agent of chaos
right I mean when you have access to
everything it's hard to be something and
it we don't know what this extension of
our nervous system because that's
definitely what the social media
platforms are we don't know what that
extension exactly is going to do for us
and you know you made reference back to
some of the earlier points you made in
the discussion is that you guys are
trying to identify your core values and
to leave them in Bedrock position in
your culture and you're hoping that that
will enable your young people to turn to
the benefits of our interconnectedness
without falling prey to the possibility
of chaos being induced you know it's
very hard to set up a complex
information system that's
optimally what interconnected so the
brain is set up so that it has areas
that that only communicate locally and
then those areas communicate distally
like every neuron isn't connected to
every other neuron you get nothing but
chaos in that situation and so there has
to be a balance between order and
stability and and connectivity and we
are all wrestling with that around the
world right I mean these new
technologies are absolutely amazing but
they definitely do have the the
possibility of spreading chaos at at the
same rate they
they they distribute benevolent
information I think that again goes to
the way we want this generation
to raise and grow uh part of it we take
full responsibility on uh I think we
should take full accountability and
responsibility on what are the values we
want to embed in the community's DNA in
our family's DNA and and how do we do
that often in different doses we do it
in school we do it at home we do it in
University we do it in workplaces I'll
give you an example uh I had a program
called the national values program here
at the United Arab Emirates and one one
of the main products of that program was
to actually measure values in the
society and in the community so we used
to do social
experiments and then one of the social
experiments I said okay let's let's take
a permission where we have a car by the
side of the street where uh someone who
needs help with his mechanics of his car
his car is not working it's at 2 p.m
afternoon in the summer uh it's a time
where maybe most people would be busy
having lunch with their families and we
said let's let's record that and see how
many actually young imatis with come and
provide help or Provide support Jordan
in one
hour the number of people who
actually stopped and paused their
journey to where wherever they were
heading and paused by and parked beside
that car to actually offer help it was
more than 15 young people they decided
to actually
voluntarily uh something in them felt
that oh I should offer help and that's
something I see on daily basis uh I
don't think you will see a single
incident where we think twice before uh
providing support or before uh providing
help to people around and that's that
value that's part of that tradition of
hospitality yes that was part of our
generation's hospitality and the way we
have been raised but then My ultimate
concern is always I have to be as good
as my father and my grandfather and
building that and my daughter and
building that in the Next Generation to
ensure that I embed the same values uh
that grows in her the way I saw it
happening in me and in many other people
during one of my latest visits I was
waiting for for a plane and watching the
news on
TV and there were an incident in one of
the cities in the western world where
someone was being killed in a
Subway and people were filming that and
people were standing still and filming
that it's scary to me at that moment I
felt where are we heading as human
beings that's something I don't want to
ever see not in 50 years but in 100
years in our country and I'm sure it
won't happen because we are taking full
responsibility and accountability on
defining who we are uh because that have
been happening since 1971 and it will
keep happening till
2071 uh for the years ahead but then
also that reminds me to a story we all
know Cain and Abel uh I think uh yes
Cain was angry he was jealous of his
brother and he ended up killing him but
then if you look at the word today I
think can and it will exist almost in
every single community and sometimes
maybe some maybe some people would say
they exist even in you uh but then you
decide on who wins and you decide that
you never allowed to cbel in your
community or you cbel in yourself and
that's something very very important to
us because we know we know that
sometimes in some communities and we saw
it happening people lose it I think they
lose the idea of being a human being the
being part gets lost uh they they don't
Define their values or they don't Define
what's right and what's wrong uh I think
that's something we do very well and my
ultimate passion is to continue to do
that I want to close this with an
invitation to you um I've been working
with a group of people
uh centered in London but um with active
participants all through Europe and
Australia and Canada and the US um and
then increasingly in other places in the
world where we can manage the reach we
have a conference coming up in London at
the end of October October 31st 30th
31st and November 1st and followed by a
public uh um event at the O2 um the
group is the alliance for responsible
citizenship and what we're trying to do
is to formulate a positive story for the
future a positive vision and uh I would
like to extend an invitation to you and
also uh uh what would you say a codicil
on that invitation it would be
delightful and helpful if you could help
also help us identify key people that we
might invite in the UAE and in your
broader network of contacts to bring
people there because we want to get
everybody on board to the degree that
that's possible and we are doing kind of
what we discussed during this podcast
you know we want to put together a
vision of the future that isn't going to
involve compulsion and force but that
offers an active invitation to the kind
of future that we might all want to have
if we could pick the future we would
actually want to have if we were being
able and not cane let's say and so you
know it sounds like our interests in
that regard are very much aligned so and
I'm also looking very much forward to
coming to the UAE and to meeting you in
person and to seeing what's going on in
there and I would like to thank you um
for talking to me and to everybody else
here today to clue Us in about the
positive developments um in the Middle
East I mean we've in the west you know
we've sat through Decades of stories of
misery and Dread emanating from the
Middle East and you know that's kind of
part for the historical course in some
ways and it's so bloody positive to see
things switch around and to see peace
break out and to see the possibility of
real generous cooperation emerge and so
you know congratulations on that front
it's such a major accomplishment and
hopefully that ethos can spread
throughout the Arab world and and
everywhere else wouldn't that be
good uh Jordan will thank thank you for
hosting me thank you for your invitation
uh you're a psychologist and I think you
know that feeling when you have a dinner
with your wife and you eat something
that tasty and delicious and you you go
and tell her oh I think you should try
this or you watched a movie that's uh
somehow moved apart on you and then you
said oh I think you should watch this
movie
is that feeling where you want the other
side or the other part
uh or the other community or friends or
family to enjoy what you have enjoyed or
to actually have something good or
experience something good as you did it
as a human being and I think that
feeling you would see it in Mar UA
Nationals we feel our leadership did and
built something that works and something
that shows results something that built
hope something that
made me feel um Unstoppable when it
comes to serving when it comes to
building something better uh and I wish
I see that in more communities I wish I
see that in many different areas because
I have tasted it I have lived it I have
experienced it and that that's my
ultimate purpose in life to actually
help others see the good we so and or
experience because part of being who we
are or part of defining uh your purpose
is seeing the good in others and having
a good impact in on others as well well
Amen to that brother so well I'll see
you in the UAE in not so many months and
I'm looking forward to collaborating
with you on that front and to having you
in London and uh for everyone watching
and listening I'm going to continue
speaking with s on the dailywire plus
platform um we're going to delve a
little bit more into his personal
history and to um discussion on the
autobiographical front and uh so give
some consideration to joining us there
if you're inclined um otherwise I'll say
sayanora to you all and thank you very
much for your time and attention to the
film crew here um in Northern Ontario
and um also in the UAE thanks for your
participation and always to the Daily
Weare plus folks for making this
possible it's much appreciated very good
to talk with you sir and uh we'll take
five and for the rest of you watching
and listening um you know join me in the
next podcast as well very good to talk
to you today thank you thank you do I
enjoyed the
conversation I
think I see your Clips more often in the
feed of our young people uh I see my
nephews watching some of your Clips
because actually your content when it
comes to setting goals sitting Vision uh
character building or exploring
character and a lot of the values you
are speaking about it's somehow the same
language we understand yeah and we see
uh I'm not sure how much you dig deep
into the culture of the Middle East the
W and the Islamic W but I could say the
the the areas where we could see
alignment Agreements are huge and that
repres presentent who we are I think it
does the the news you hear about this
region and the conflicts and the people
of this region I think we we again we
didn't do enough when authoring our own
story many people spoke about who we are
but I think we know better who we are
and we should send that narrative to the
whole
world great well you know all of that uh
shared Foundation means that in
principle we have something to build
solid to build on in the future and so
you know hoay for that all right good to
talk to you sir bye-bye
[Music]
everybody